[Music]
Scot good morning how's the voice today
it's great dad and look at you still
doing a sports thing yeah plugging away
every day at the grinder just a grinder
yeah I'm sort of The Brady of talk-radio
just grind it I don't I agree yeah you
know I'm sure you're paid accordingly
yes Thomas and married to a supermodel
absolutely all the same parallels there
what did you expect before yesterday's
game anxiety going into it because you
know the element of the unknown they
didn't play a clean game against Houston
so that was a concern
you know the turnovers and but you know
the attitude of Brady last week and
people are like well he said I'm like
he's not sick he's pissed off ticked off
he knows what's his door and if they
protected the football I think they were
confident going in knowing that they
could spread Pittsburgh out see Houston
had a pretty good fun they can get after
you you know merciless and clowny the
level they're playing at but um ain't
I've been I've been around this
quarterback for the last 18 20 months
and he's been on this mission for his
for his ability to just internalize
everything and just keep it to himself
such a class act and it's a shame how
he's been scuffle it is I'm fairly
persecuted how do you think now we know
how he's treated in New England but how
do you think the rest of the country
looks at braiding pretty much how mike
tomlin probably did you know after the
Kansas City game I mean the evil
villains its yeah you remember when the
Yankees won in the 90s the amount of
championships and you know how he hated
Jeter here and hates a strong word
nobody hates anybody but I guess they're
unlikable nationally you know we were
there all the time
dan I've been doing the broadcast now
for six years six to eight years that's
my sixth straight AFC championship game
that I've called I think that's the norm
here this is that's what we do you know
but uh spray D to vellum jackets
attention to detail and hey this team
works hard and so does this ownership
group too great organization to be a
part of are you ever muffled at all
anybody ever say go too far or not far
enough or watch what you say no
think I think I know you know the type
of lines you can and can't push and yeah
I think that I do for our radio show
each and every day so there's another
platform to get after some things but I
pride myself on call and like to see it
if it's good it's good if it's bad it's
bad and I'd say it man and just this is
life and you know his team his team's
gone through some tough stretches here
and they've handled adversity quite well
this year is there a what's the weakness
on this team
great question I mean it's easy to
really go to the defensive side and say
you know what they can't really cover
guys that well they had issues early in
a year and you look at that Seattle game
and you know you get rid of a guy like
Jamie Collins you trade Chandler Jones
away they bring in Kyle van Noy Shane
McClelland and Lena Roberts it's a high
tire off the film last night
he's got the Green Dot call the signals
because of the matchup they're unselfish
I don't know what the weakness is I
really don't I mean going to Super Bowls
out Rob Gronkowski you know you know but
Martellus Bennett has been great you
talk about another grinder guys played
hurt all year I don't know what the
weaknesses I really don't know defense
was playing well Scott so like the
Patriots radio broadcaster for 98.5 the
Sports Hub but you know here's Belichick
he's not afraid to trade somebody in the
offseason not afraid to trade somebody
during the season and these are
defensive starters that he's not afraid
to part with and I think people thought
man he's losing it like what what has
happened here is his ego getting in the
way doesn't want to deal with these guys
who want big paychecks where we know
he's not afraid to get rid of marquee
players but this is right before the
season and right during the season Scott
it sounded crazy
any time you survive the stretch without
brain you go three and one you think
everything's okay then you go to Buffalo
you wanted Buffalo but some didn't look
right upfront and whether it was Jamie
Collins out of position and hey let's
say so Jamie's a fantastic player he's
probably one of the best athletes I've
ever been around watch play and I've
done some stuff in the offseason with
him you're just a good kid that
something wasn't clicking I'm fun and
whether it was attention to detail not
listening to the calls gap
responsibilities and Bill had enough
and he said you know what we're not
gonna listen if we're not gonna do it
I'm gonna do things my way and if
anybody's like it and get the hell out
and the just a transformation this
defense has made over the last eight
weeks is you know everybody's going to
talk about Brady and the points and
legacies 17 years in the Brady belcheck
combination this defense you know at
times has carried this team here
especially late here finish this
sentence if the Commissioner had
attended yesterday's game he would have
gotten booed I mean yeah I mean there's
been a lot said about this guy and he
should have buried the hatchet really
torn like a one o'clock Rams game or
something but the fact he stayed away is
let this thing turn really into a
dumpster fire now for the point where
you know the fan base really doesn't
want to see him there in Foxborough but
um yeah if he was there yesterday we got
booed on mercifully do you think there
could have been an incident yesterday no
no I really I like where an angry fan
base talks to the fan base but you
really got to be an idiot if you think
there's some sort of a physical incident
that really would have taken place and
it's a war of words and you just feel
like you violated the quarterback of
which and I talked about this commanding
stuff too and you know people are like
wow you know you got this clinic maybe
pay I'm like Tom Brady and Peyton
Manning have been the best ambassadors
for the National Football League when
these two guys are gone good luck trying
to replace him and just the attack that
you know everybody fills Brady's been
under and that's just you know get to
the Super Bowl win the Super Bowl and
that's the way you get back at it I I
read and heard that Brady could be
playing for his job yesterday if he lost
the game that somehow you know Jimmy
Garoppolo come on down you know just
another man do you think where Ruffalo
is there next year I don't know I don't
know how he is
I really don't because I think the value
for that type of guy you're gonna guy
like Osweiler 18 million dollars a year
Jimmy's pretty darn good he's damn good
and you know the way he was trending
especially that Miami game and the value
you could probably get in return
you could get a one in a two probably
for him and Tom's not going anywhere I
mean you see any precipitous drop in
play
no no that's when Belichick moves on
what he's got an issue with the player
where you see the drop in play he will
cut bait there's no reason to cut bait
with Tom Brady right cut bait with Tom
Brady right now is the fire alarm guy a
hero or a loser loser yeah I mean hey we
we were to Super Bowl two years ago fire
line got pulled three times during the
Super Bowl week it happens to everybody
it's like the heads that's right
everybody thinks they come to Foxborough
and you got headset pops it happens
across the leak you know I mean now on
the side you got first responders that
are taken out of beds you know you're
sitting there wait and say something
seriously happen and you take some of
the people to protect us out of it you
know you don't pull fire alarms it's
it's a stupid prank well keep stirring
it up there's Scott maybe we'll cross
paths in Houston and thanks for joining
us all right let's cazzo Lac I think I
probably did some highlights when Scott
was quarterbacking that makes me old the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]